president biden just made his first late
night tv appearance in person since
taking office he visited jimmy kimmel
live last night as his approval rating
hit the lowest level of his presidency
late last night the late night talk show
host has been a frequent campaign stop
for decades but politicians also use
them to appear comfortable and relatable
especially to a younger audience as ed
o'keefe reports the president used that
more casual setting to highlight some of
the most pressing issues facing the
nation
this is not your father's republican
party this is a maga party
president biden used his time on jimmy
kimmel live not only to discuss the
nation's problems
but also to make clear the actions he's
taking to solve them voting rights
climate change the all these things in
some ways we've we've moved backwards
well on climate change we've actually
made some real moves his appearance
comes amid sinking approval ratings as
he grapples with soaring gas prices and
inflation and russia's invasion of
ukraine i made gridlock in congress it's
like you're playing monopoly with
somebody who you know won't pass go and
won't follow any of the rules and how do
you ever make any progress if they're
not
following the rules
you know
the president appears to be trying to
connect with americans on a more
personal level something many white
house hopefuls have done for decades on
late night tv senator from massachusetts
mr john kennedy
john f kennedy was the first to do it
when he joined jack parr on the tonight
show in 1960. the united states is
really the only
guardian at the gate against the
communist advance but the candidate
played it straight
eight years later richard nixon flipped
the script by appearing on the sketch
show laughing suck it to me
through the years it's often become
something of a talent show for
candidates and presidents alike
[Music]
we were able to stimulate the economy
and get our country back on track
but it wasn't until 2009.
that the first sitting president hit the
late-night airways i do think in
washington it's a little bit like
american idol except everybody is simon
cowell wow
barack obama's successor did not appear
while in office but then candidate
donald trump did make some late night
headlines can i mess your hair up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
these days the white house knows many
people are watching late night clips the
next morning on social media rather than
tuning in at night and the president is
also using humor to reach a younger
generation online
but comedic timing on twitter isn't
quite like television when you have
sensitive documents that you need to
flush down the toilet do you do that
is that done in your office toilet or is
that done in the bathroom in the
personal bathroom area i call trump
that video with bts quickly became one
of the most watched videos produced by
the white house during the biden
presidency we should point out he's
officially out here to lead the summit
of the americas and president biden will
be doing something that other commanders
in chief have done while in california
he'll be raising some big campaign cash
from hollywood donors
tony a lot of rich guys out there we
shall see if that appearance improves
the president's approval ratings ed
thank you very much